senior national security analyst Fran
Townsend spent 13 years working in the
Justice Department she oversaw the unit
that handled the FISA warrants and was
also homeland security adviser to
President George W Bush Fran much to
discuss about this story if the FBI does
release a rebuttal what would that look
like to you well it's it's complicated
for them Gail because of course what
they worry about is revealing sources
and methods director raised real
objection here is that the noonas memo
is a one-sided advocacy piece and he
wants to put it in context he wants to
do that without revealing sort of how
they collect information no FISA warrant
is on a single piece of information so
even if you relied in some part on the
steal dossier in a warrant one you would
have had to caveat it in terms of your
concerns about the credibility of the
sourcing on it and two it wouldn't have
been the only thing you would have had
informants you might have had other
physical surveillance you might have had
other electronic surveillance you might
have had information from foreign
intelligence services and so it's a
mosaic you've got to think of these
warrants as one thing yeah well and the
memo alleges that of course that it was
the steeled dossier that set off the
surveillance of Carter page I have to is
read The Wall Street Journal today to
see he's been likely under surveillance
since 2013 for a number of meetings he'd
had he even lived in Moscow back in 2004
so there's a lot of other evidence out
there to be taken in context aleut Lee
the president heard from his FBI
director and decided to go in another
direction is that just a disagreement
that bosses have with their subordinates
or is there a break here that's going to
leave lasting damage you know I talked
to several sources inside the FBI who
made perfectly clear that this is a
professional disagreement Kriss ray is
the directors not looking at crosswise
with the president he understands they
may disagree it's the president's
decision and they're gonna move forward
so I don't think we ought to view this
as a big break between the director and
the president but I mean look if you're
the director you got to not feel pretty
you have to not feel good about the
president deciding the director used the
words grave concern Fran that's right I
mean I look I think because it really
undermines the integrity and credibility
of the FBI and the long-term potential
impact of that is your foreign allies
who you rely on to share classified
information with you
to prevent threats to this country may
not share it with you if they have to
worry about it becoming public you think
this changes the process for getting a
FISA warrant going forward if you think
that it's gonna be reviewed in this
context well I think I think you're
gonna be more careful about what you put
in it if you're worried about it being
revealed I mean and that's the very
thing we don't want to happen right this
is a very sort of constrained process
and very careful process and you want
the court to have all the potential
information they can what you don't want
is people holding things back because
they're afraid it's gonna be revealed is
there some suggestion that it could
undermine the credibility of the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein you know
the big concern here rod Rosenstein has
been a target of presidents Trump's
criticisms and I think people worry he's
unlikely to fire Muller because of what
that controversy would be but if he took
out rod Rosenstein he's really the
principal lawyer overseeing the Muller
investigation and whoever he replaces
him with could fire Muller is the
current the thinking
thanks a lot friend